[Music]
yourselves hey matt
how can we get back on the right track
[Applause]
well as i see it there is only one
solution
and that is for me to get my gear
moving on in here cause i'm gonna bunk
with you buddy
we're gonna be buddies we're gonna be
pals we're gonna rattle around
oh man it's gonna be your shadow
here's you here's matt there's you there
hey there it's mark and welcome to a
brand new episode of rt essentials don't
you just love a compelling tv series the
magnetic characters the engaging
dialogue the enchanting worlds we rise
and fall with the drama we cry and laugh
with the comedies and when an episode
ends we yearn for the next one to air
okay so maybe there's not a whole lot of
yearning going on all the time we
probably just hit the play the next
episode button and maybe skip the
opening credits but those seconds feel
like a lifetime when a show is just that
good and there's nothing better than
seeing the shows we love receive the
credit that they so deserve especially
in the form of an award but not just any
award nay a symbol of excellence in
american prime time television
programming bestowed by the academy of
television arts and sciences aka an emmy
countless shows have taken home emmy
since the ceremony first took place some
73 years ago we were so young but only a
select few have managed to triumph want
to know which show has won the most
emmys stick around i now present the
most any winning tv of all time
the sopranos
seriously what about adults here right
so
after all is shed and done
if they want complaining and the crying
and all the
is this all there is
up versus the sopranos created by david
chase and originally premiering on hbo
in january of 1999. i will do my best to
avoid spoilers and don't worry i'm not
going to discuss that
controversial finale but really
what happened there man i love journey
why spend so much time focusing on
meadows lousy parking shop and seriously
look you're just going to cut to black
after all we've been through i called my
cable company and was on hold for 90
minutes sorry i'm getting carried away
that's because the show meant a lot to
fans like myself and it meant a whole
lot to the medium of television in
general but don't take my word for it
the writers guild of america named it
the best written tv series of all time
rolling stone ranked it first in their
list of 100 greatest tv shows ever and
the bbc called it a revolutionary show
we'll talk about forever and to think
all this from a slice of gaba ghoul
it's an inside joke you really got to
watch the show like bremen glace
yeah you bless it i'll eat it she's not
coming no grandma just called
started crying and hung up she needs a
purpose in life no your mother is
tougher than you think so what no
friends eating now hey the sopranos ran
for six seasons 86 episodes redefined
the crime drama and presented one of the
most notorious anti-heroes to ever grace
the small screen in tony soprano with
elevated storytelling and inspired
performances from james gandolfini
lorraine bronco and edie falco it's no
wonder the series won 21 emmys out of
112 nominations earning an outstanding
drama series nomination every single
year it was eligible yes tony and the
gang certainly rose to the top the must
have felt incredible and all that
respect but i still have no freaking
idea what it's like to truly be number
one tony does i think
modern family
oh my god that was so easy this is
awesome you really don't understand what
just happened there do you pj's on haley
what um i would be happy to let her
change in my room
modern family was a mockumentary sitcom
that offered an honest and often
hilarious perspective of present-day
family life the series was created by
christopher lloyd and steven levitan and
premiered on abc in september of 2009
though a sitcom exploring the inner
workings of close relatives wasn't
anything new this series was considered
revolutionary because of its execution
critics praised the hilarious writing
the relatable characters and believable
acting the documentary style device and
the topical themes like the role that
technology currently plays in parenting
many consider the series to be a much
needed spark in the sitcom genre and
from the first episode critics and
audiences alike were hooked with los
angeles times writing that modern family
has single-handedly brought the family
comedy back from the dead that's high
praise indeed but let's not beat around
the bush we all know why we're here
modern family won a total of 22 emmys
out of 75 nominations it won best
outstanding comedy series each of its
first five seasons on air julie bowen
won for outstanding supporting actress
twice and both eric stonestreet and ty
burrell each one for outstanding
supporting actor twice we haven't
unwrapped our secret weapon yet
luke walks over there hurt locker style
flips the switch
and boom
not boom
water off
put the he in hero son
as if we needed another reason to love
this cast when it came time to submit
their names for the emmys all the actors
submitted in the supporting category
instead of vying for the lead position
with tv veteran ed o'neal explaining
that nobody is bigger than anybody else
in a show that is evolving into a true
ensemble hit like a real family the cast
stuck together i gotta say o'neil's come
a long way since his days of endlessly
insulting customers at gary's shoes
the daily show with jon stewart i've got
stuart we got a very very good show
tonight uh my guest tonight howard
schultz will be here he is the ceo of
starbucks um
actually he's just here to use our
bathroom but i'm making him buy
something
uh congratulations to the u.s we beat
ghana six nil
and now a moment of sin for the daily
show with jon stewart originally airing
on comedy central stewart took over his
host in january of 1999 and satirical
news programs would never be the same
critics and audiences were immediately
receptive to stewart's quick wit and
charm and soon the show took on a new
life diving even deeper into political
issues and ramping up election coverage
especially in 2000 and 2004
in addition to stewart's news desk
reports the series combined tape field
pieces in studio interviews and
recurring bits and much of the show's
personality and comedic direction can be
attributed to stewart's experience
working as an editor for the onion
actually several of his colleagues at
the onion were also hired as writers on
the daily show and now that i say it out
loud that makes a lot of sense in your
case there is white privilege
thank you fact that you're here sitting
there and i've said it many times on the
factor the highest rated cable news show
in the world all right
the african-americans haven't seen megan
kelly yet
oh
she's crushing you dude
she's crushing you now you're misleading
she's crushing you you're misleading all
right during stewart's 16-year stint the
daily show won 23 emmys out of 60
nominations those wins included
outstanding variety series which it won
10 years in a row outstanding writing
for a variety series and outstanding
directing for a variety series
additionally the daily show influenced a
successful comedy central spin-off the
colbert rapport colbert having been a
correspondent originally on the daily
show
trevor noah took over hosting duties in
september of 2015 and the show continues
to be a trusted news source with plenty
of comic relief
er i didn't know that pediatricians
could be so sexy and i said honey
you ain't seen nothing yet
[Music]
right
all right give me a fast drip i need the
hydration don't worry don't just lie
back
ho ho how's your beautiful wife how's
jennifer
she's fine really you two settle your
problems yeah yeah everything's okay i
hate to lose you in the er you know
author michael crichton originally
imagined er as a feature film based on
his own experiences working in a busy
emergency room crafting an initial
script back in 1974. by the way i know
what you're thinking yes this is the
same michael crichton who wrote the
jurassic park novel which i hear they
made a movie out of a lot of people
don't realize it but spielberg was
involved in the creation of er as well
his company amblin entertainment
produced the show along with warner
brothers and using most of creighton's
original script they aired a two-hour
pilot movie on nbc in september of 1994.
once nbc fully ordered the series and
gave it the thursday night time slot it
was game over people couldn't get enough
of this medical drama set in chicago the
infectious cast get it what i did there
which included julianna margulies and
george clooney the abundance of
high-stakes situations synonymous with
hospitals and of course did we mention
george clooney's in it also george
clooney anthony edwards goose and also
george clooney's on the show anyways
critics praised it with the guardian
writing that the speed is both
ridiculous and breathtaking but
perfectly paced and the washington post
called it an antidote to bad tv
temperature as you see he's gotten 500
cc saline crits 32.5 type and cross
match sent x-rays waiting and the or
says they'll have a room in 10 minutes
okay let's get them out of here
so uh do you think you can save the hand
looks pretty good i think so good i told
him you could so he's counting on you
peter you're a smart ass you'd love to
do this case yourself wouldn't you
yeah
i'm ready i'm strong here i could do it
you're a resident peter you're years
from a case like this
yes the show is beloved from the jump
but what does that matter if it never
received the accolades it deserved uh
what's that during its 15 seasons er won
23 out of 124 emmy nominations okay but
probably not for any of the important
categories right oh no pretty much all
of them all right cool you got your
outstanding drama series your
outstanding directing outstanding
supporting actress outstanding sound
mixing outstanding casting outstanding
guest actress and outstanding
and outstanding george clooney
performance yeah i made that one up but
come on can we make it a category the
guy deserves it the west wing does the
whole town really have to be together to
stone my brother john for planting
different crops side by side can i burn
my mother in a small family gathering
for wearing garments made from two
different threads
think about those questions would you
one last thing
while you may be mistaking this for your
monthly meeting of the ignorant tight
ass club in this building when the
president stands
nobody sits the west wing was a
political drama that originally aired on
nbc and ran for seven seasons
154 episodes the series is centered
around fictional president jed bartlett
played by martin sheen and his team of
advisors who get their personal lives
hopelessly tangled up with their
professional duties all while trying to
successfully run some country called the
united states the series was created by
aaron sorkin who many consider to be one
of the greatest living screenwriters and
playwrights his work speaks for itself
you got a few good men charlie wilson's
war moneyball steve jobs and the social
network which actually earned him an
oscar for best adapted screenplay look
the guy's got writing chops and it's no
wonder that the west wing has been
consistently praised for its sharp
dialogue and intricate storytelling time
magazine wrote that nothing walked and
talked quite likely and it's just so
true viewers were immersed in the
fast-paced political world major
decisions that affect the lives of
millions are made in an instant and
despite such consequential subject
matter the show always managed to find
moments of levity i'm alone
i'm bucking him up leave him alone you
asked me to buck him up now i'm telling
you to leave him alone guys i'm trying
to watch the speech
josh
hi senator why don't you take your
legislative agenda and shove it up your
ass
turns out i was fine the west wing holds
the record for the most emmys won by a
series in its first season with a total
of nine it won the emmy for outstanding
drama series four years in a row tying
hill street blues mad men l.a law and
game of thrones for the most wins in
that category and also shares the emmy
award record for most acting nominations
by red your cast members in total the
west wing won 26 out of 95 emmy
nominations and continues to rank high
on lists of the greatest tv shows of all
time
cheers well how about the one where you
go to this fancy restaurant and before
they let you in they make you leave your
legs at the door
and the girl gives you claim check
number six so you go in but instead of
food everyone's eating their silverware
well you can't really enjoy your fork
because you're so worried that whoever
got claim check number nine might finish
first and pick up your legs by mistake
sometimes you wanna go where everybody
knows your name
they sing it better but other times you
just wanna be by yourself and binge
classic tv shows like cheers which
originally aired on nbc in september of
1982. it follows sam malone a former red
sox pitcher who owns and runs a cozy
little bar in beantown malone interacts
with a slew of wacky characters that
frequent the bar like the beer loving
norm who appeared in all
275 episodes of the series oh oh blind
date isn't that a little risky there not
in this case coach
what's there
foreign
oh sammy watching you get ready for a
date is watching that great matador
prepare for a bull fight
i hate that stuff you know who wants to
see a guy go and manipulate and torment
a poor unthinking creature like that hey
i always buy him breakfast don't i
unlike many of the other shows on this
list cheers was a slow burn having
almost been canceled during its first
season due to poor ratings actually just
about the poorest ratings you could have
at the time ranking 74th out of 77 shows
but thanks to serious critical support
and an nbc president who saw the show's
potential and refused to give up cheers
eventually climbed its way out of the
viewership dugout and ended up earning a
top 10 rating during eight of its 11
seasons and it had one of the most
watched single episodes of the 1990s the
finale entitled one for the road which
over 42 million households tuned in for
that's roughly 40 percent of the u.s
population at the time
cheers won emmy's for outstanding comedy
series outstanding lead actor and
actress outstanding directing in a
comedy series outstanding supporting
actress and actor outstanding writing in
a comedy series and many others for a
total of 28 wins out of 117 nominations
it also spawned the successful spin-off
frasier
more on dr crane in just a little bit
the simpsons it's the land of my
innermost thoughts and fondest desires
at last we'll get to the bottom welcome
back handsome
[Music]
marge this is my friend peggy
finally something animated good grief
the simpsons is the longest running
american sitcom and the longest running
scripted prime time television series in
history running for 33 seasons and
728 episodes since his debut in december
of 1989 and it's still going strong with
fox releasing season 34 in the fall of
2022 believe it or not it still isn't
the longest running series on this list
so hold that thought set in the town of
springfield the show centers around the
titure simpsons family consisting of
donut addicted father homer blue-haired
matriarch marge their trouble-making son
bart overachieving daughter lisa and
baby maggie chances are you've seen the
show and even if you somehow managed to
avoid it you know what a simpson looks
like that's because this show has an
unrivaled influence on pop culture and
has pushed the boundaries of what an
animated series could be by touching on
adult themes and political issues in a
hilarious manner hello i'd like to speak
with a mr snot ball first name euro
you're a snot ball what how dare you if
i find out who this is i'll staple a
flag to your butt and mail you to it
paved the way for shows like south park
family guy american dad and futurama and
in addition to garnering a devout fan
base that spans the globe the series has
received unanimous critical praise
entertainment weekly nailed it when they
said the simpsons are the american
family at its most complicated drawn as
simple cartoons
i could go on and on empire named it the
greatest tv show of all time the writers
guild of america listed as the 11th best
written series ever tv guide listed it
as the greatest tv cartoon of all time
and so on and so on don't have a cow if
you don't get to everybody let's get
down to business the simpsons has won 35
out of 98 emmy nominations including
wins for outstanding animated program
outstanding voiceover performance and
outstanding music and lyrics but you
know what's even cooler homer's
catchphrase doe was officially added to
the oxford english dictionary in 2001.
frasier stephanie would you please turn
off that vacuum cleaner
it's not a vacuum cleaner it's the dirt
scourge 2000 a total cleansing system
is it new yeah got it this afternoon you
see this water traps all the dirt
particles instead of recycling them back
into the air i got all that just from dr
crane's pillow
i've been begging you to switch to a
more abrasive loofah and we're back
let's get straight to dr crane a
successful boston therapist who moved to
seattle to get a new start on life and i
hear he's listening he hosts a
successful radio talk show which he uses
to relay his wit and wisdom to others
but often struggles with problems of his
own like how to deal with his salt of
the earth father and his pretentious
brother niles but hey there's nothing
some top shelf sherry can't solve okay
that's not entirely true no matter how
much sherry was consumed and there was a
lot it didn't help to resolve the will
they won't they dynamic between niles
and daphne i mean it eventually got
sorted out after keeping us in suspense
for like seven seasons wow seven seasons
even i moved quicker than that
or some boys go to college but we think
they're overseas because they get all
the knowledge and we get all them
all right i'll do it
frasier originally aired on nbc and ran
for 11 seasons
264 episodes critics praised the
performances notably kelsey grammer in
the titular role and additionally the
show was lauded for its impeccable
writing but the question we're asking
today how did it fare during award
season frasier won 37 emmys out of 107
nominations surpassing the mary tyler
moore show for the most wins for a
scripted series until that record was
surpassed by another little show we'll
be discussing next i love foreshadowing
frazier's wins included outstanding
comedy series which had took home a
record breaking five times from 1994 to
1998 an outstanding lead actor for
grammar which he took home four times
david hyde pierce who plays frasier's
brother niles also won four times for
outstanding supporting actor because as
we know from watching the show niles was
not gonna let his brother outshine him
game of thrones
[Applause]
don't talk any show that must say i am
the king is no true king but in the
battle of emmys game of thrones really
does reign supreme it was such a massive
story with so many characters easily the
largest ensemble cast in history we
could spend an entire episode just
discussing one of the families like the
lannisters or the stars heck we could
spend 10 episodes just analyzing the
maps of westeros and essos the point is
when it comes to world building george
r.r martin is on another level entirely
you got tolkien and rowling in there and
series creators david benioff and db
weiss had their work cut out for them
when it came to adapting martin's work
for the small screen it's safe to say
i think they did all right i'd hate to
die like your son
clawing at my neck
not at all what i intended
you see
i'd never seen the poison work before
tell sassy
i wanted to know it was me
game of thrones premiered on hbo in
april of 2011 ran for eight seasons and
received mostly unanimous critical
praise not going to talk about that last
season too much let's table that for
another episode time magazine wrote with
its shocking plot twists dark themes and
giant budget thrones became a phenomenon
and a cultural touch point and it's true
the show's had an immeasurable impact on
our culture especially in the
entertainment industry but when you play
the game of enemies you win or you die
and game of thrones what like really
really won the series took home and
astonishing
59 emmys out of 160 nominations
surpassing the record held by frasier
for total emmy wins for a scripted
television series these wins included
outstanding drama series four times and
outstanding special visual effects it
looks like the battle's over and they
have won and it's time to lay down
ourselves no wait uh oh there's another
series
saturday night live what seemed bad so
jealous
you know you've always been my little
girl
and
that's why i have your name tattooed
right above my heart
ew dad don't show it oh
live from new york it's saturday night
live now known as snl a late night
sketch comedy and variety series that
has aired on nbc for 47
seasons yes you heard that right the
show's been on and more or less thriving
since it first premiered way back in
october of 1975.
fun fact comedy legend george carlin was
the first host of snl ever i mean you
talk about setting the tone for the
decades of laughs that followed that's a
pretty good horse to back your cart with
the formula for snl has pretty much
remained the same since the show's
inception a celebrity guest will host
usually delivering an opening monologue
sketches are acted out by the cast and
the host and a musical guest will play a
couple of tunes maybe some news is
sprinkled in if it ain't broke don't fix
it
he's going to the bathroom in these
oversized fake office supplies i go to
the bathroom what is wrong with you why
would you do that voiceover said it
would save time for business what are
you been working on i don't know i've
been too busy going to the bathroom
i was like
in here
am i fired yes
and take that
with you right yeah of course
much like game of thrones we could spend
episodes discussing snl all the
hilarious sketches the legendary actors
and comedians they got their start on
the series yep steve martin who was
never even a cast member tina fey adam
sandler chris farley and too many others
to name but we all know why we're here
drumroll please
snl has won 86 emmy awards out of
307 nominations that's the most emmy
wins and nominations for any show ever
you can go ahead and drop all your mics
and it's unlikely that another series
will ever be able to catch up to that so
hats off to lauren michaels who himself
has taken home 20 emmys and is the most
nominated individual in the award show's
history and that wraps up our list of
the most emmy-winning tv of all time we
couldn't include every series to ever
clean up at the prestigious awards show
but fear not we got plenty of episodes
of rt essentials coming your way so i'm
sure we'll get there eventually thanks
again for tuning in i'm mark ellis and
to all you aspiring creatives out there
now is the time to write that pilot
you've been putting off just think in 40
years you could catch up to snl in the
meantime we'll see you next time on rt
essentials bye-bye
[Applause]
[Music]